so what we determined was that these
guys are not just going to carry than
that here but they're actually about
intimately connected and we noted it we
don't let it first through a geometric
estrella she measured properly which was
about reflectivity do you remember that
right I if for example you're in two
spots in a whisper gallery two very
specific spots
if you speak a very quiet voice and
someone at the other point which was
what were those two points always
thinking about them there were the foci
right if you're at one of the two
focuses you can hear are very clearly
just by what's very common so if at this
shape the circle of course we thought
okay this uh this is for the ellipse
right we determined that rather than
just having one focus like the problem
because you've got this symmetry we
talked about the symmetry there's two
different axes we call them the four
with the names in the major minor axes
one's longer than the other because
you've got these major minor axes of
symmetry which is the prevalent doesn't
this brothers just got one axis of
symmetry that's why you could say we
know what I could generate this ellipse
I could generate it by saying look just
have a look at at that time right or
just as equally I could do it from the
other side right so being that either of
them like both of them behind equally
valid competitors for the time loop I'm
the real quickest way you just have to
say they're right they're right but as
you climb back into this right it's like
well you don't get a directory city
board or you could say it has an
infinite number of dresses and you just
got the one in the center you guys kind
of migrated into the middle and
coalesced right which was the reverse of
what we said was happening with
eccentricity
where do we start with we get a
numerical definition for eccentricity in
general right
what is x intricity it's uh it's a ratio
between the distance to the focus and
the distance to the directrix right so
you've got this kind of scenario we said
and I better do this a bit closer so it
actually gonna look a little bit
accurate we said with the problems
required familiar with every point every
point if you compare the distance of the
focus to the directrix from that point
of the luckiest the ratio should be one
to one one to one
we're very familiar that we've sort of
done that to them so that's that one to
one this year okay but all the ellipse
you're getting a different kind of
relationship something like this
distance to this distance right maybe
that might be one to two right so we
would say the eccentricity was a half we
took that idea we said well what
happened something you can't put in X
interesting equals zero because that's a
ratio can I have a ratio be zero but
through the magic of limits we
determined if you have that troops to
see me give zero this is kind of way you
end up right so here we are scenario you
said if you have an eccentricity of zero
come in a circle that's what you have if
you have an extra stirs X interesting
you've won a brother as what you can
have and anywhere between there anywhere
between there if you are bounded from
nought to one then you get the news now
the question we ended with was well what
happens we can't really have a negative
ratio that's kind of doesn't make it
makes us mutual sense as an interested
observer places what happens therefore
if you got the other dressing and you
break out posts you know extra C greater
than one okay now we will ask it Hudson
that question promise okay however
before we do that we've kind of just
really we just bet the ellipse we've
really just met here and there's a lot
more to understand
that's why I've given this the heading
but I'm wrong okay so there are two
particular things we're gonna focus on
today with the others and the little sum
here you can make example forms for the
ellipse when I say forms I kind of be
like just like my equation just have
formed right or even the equation of
parabola right I could take a parabola
and I'm going to express it in these
tips I could say x squared plus BX plus
C equals 0 and of course we would call
that chain uniform right but this is not
the only form you can express a traveler
in right what other form could I express
it in thinking in Bacchus lane because
that's kind of what I could expression
is like X minus H squared equals 4a
times y minus K is usually the
convention so this this can represent
exactly the same crap but it tells me
something different what is it tell me
it tells me where the vertex is right so
we call this we call this vertex form
right so you've got different forms
there now the forms that we're going to
explore I'm not just different versions
of the same thing but if you want to
actually have an ellipse that behaves a
little bit differently okay
all the ellipses would be looking at
having of this form so far
okay now two important things to learn
about this two point things number one
where is the center of this ellipse
where's the center it's at the origin
right now the reason we've been doing
that center zero zero the reason we've
been doing that is because it just makes
the algebra simple
it makes the numbers simpler good
morning we are we saw actually early on
what happens when you have an ellipse
and it's more of a centaur it still
works out you still end up getting
something like this but it's just it's
just messy it's harder to work I think
sets it to zeros you the other thing I
want to note is that so far and I'm
going to try and keep this consistent
we've been saying a is greater than B
like of these two numbers is the bigger
number right now do you remember on this
guy what is the significance of a and B
like what features do they tell us about
the ellipse yeah very good
this will tell you the major axis and
this is the minor axis so as an example
you know that this one else you've
already gotten in your book if you saw
this you might concluded that on the
horizontal axis where intercepts are
negative 4 & 4 and your y intercept are
negative 3 & 3 so you've gone further
this way than this way now that's your
major actions going that way okay so
what I've got here like without saying
it is the horizontal axis he's the major
axis right so I'm actually gonna like
this year like so horizontal may just
we'll talk about it as I go through your
hopefully okay
so meaning that we've got these two
features that are implied by this form
and I should say I guess I'll put one
Katara
so what we're suggesting is that a is
greater than being some some books will
not say that I hope you can see like
these are just numbers they're just
numbers you can label them however you
like like I didn't have to call this ax
squared plus BX plus C I suppose I call
I could have caught it D DX squared plus
BX plus F not a different thing just
different language with a mix some some
textbooks you will find will not call a
and B like in terms of size they'll
attach it to the X or the Y well I
should say the x squared over Y squared
okay the important thing is you pay
attention to which one is lying on so
what we're going to do is we're going to
have a look at what happens if you muck
around with each of these let's think
about moving it let's think about
translating it first and just like I
said movies yeah let's move the center
to H okay if I did that I translated H
units to the right and K units upwards
and of course if they're negative then
I'm going to go to the left and
downwards right what difference will
that make to my ex on now this is the
major axis right I haven't done any
squishing or squashing all I've done is
I just moved it I've just slid it over
okay so this guy we just talked to tells
me that proportionality is still the
same okay and in the same way just like
I have here a sort of a tangent
oh I've got Y minus case where there's
my vertical shift okay now because in
this case a still bigger than V I still
have a horizontal major axis I'm not
gonna restate that okay